bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous parler d'une stratégie infaillible
pour gagner au poker alors quand même
vous excitez pas trop vite vous allez
voir que cette méthode elle est assez
difficile à utiliser et n'espérez pas
avec devenir riche en écumant les tables
de las vegas bien les sites de poker en
ligne mais je vois qu'on pas des blagues
vous allez voir qu'il existe réellement
une méthode imbattable pour gagner au
poker
alors avant de vous parler de poker je
voudrais d'abord vous parler de quelques
autres je prenais le champion du monde
d'échecs
alors à l'heure actuelle c'est un petit
génie norvégien qui a 25 ans et qui
s'appelle magnus carlsen
il est très fort aux échecs il est même
très très fort et pourtant il n'est pas
imbattable sert que des fois il ya un
autre champion qui arrive à le battre et
puis on sait que si on le faisait jouer
contre un ordinateur fois semblablement
il y perdrait mais parce que ça fait
déjà plusieurs années que l'on sait
pertinemment que les ordinateurs sont
plus forts que les humains aux échecs et
d'ailleurs vous remarquerez qu'on
n'organise plus des compétitions de ce
genre là et pourtant même les meilleurs
programmes informatiques ils sont pas
imbattables c'est à dire qu'on peut très
bien imaginer que on va un jour arriver
à faire un programme qui sera encore
plus fort aujourd'hui ce dont je
voudrais vous parler c'est une situation
un petit peu différente c'est celle de
jeux pour lesquels il existe une
stratégie qui est mathématiquement
imbattable c'est le cas de un certain
nombre de petits jeux simples et vous
allez voir que depuis quelques mois
c'est aussi le cas du poker quand pour
un jeu des joueurs ou des mathématiciens
arrive à trouver une stratégie qui est
mathématiquement imbattable on dit que
le jeu est présenté alors il ya un
exemple assez connu de jeu qui est
parfaitement résolu c'est ce qu'on
appelle le jeu des bâtonnets vous
connaissez peut-être ce jeu si vous avez
suivi l'émission fort boyard ou alors
vous pouvez aller voir la vidéo de
micmacs qui traitent du sujet je vais
vous faire une petite démonstration de
ce que c'est que le jeu des bâtonnets en
fait ça se joue avec vingt bateaux nerfs
moi j'ai pas de bâtonnets j'ai pris les
craintes couleurs et le principe du jeu
est le suivant ça se joue à deux chaque
joueur à son tour de jouer prend 1 2 ou
3 bâtonnets et les joueurs jouent à tour
de rôle et celui qui prend le dernier
bâtonnets et déclaré le perdant alors on
va faire un petit exemple un autre
imaginons voilà on a vingt bâtonnets
alors hop le premier joueur ayant prend
par exemple 2 le deuxième joueur il en
prend trois le suivant il en prend trois
et puis lui il en prend un et puis lui 3
et lui 2 et puis lui 2
et puis lui 3 et là vous voyez que il
reste plus qu'un échange et de le
prendre et donc j'étais revenu et bien
ce jeu des bâtonnets il est résolu c'est
à dire que on connaît une stratégie qui
permette de gagner
à coup sûr cette stratégie elle est
relativement simple je vous la donne si
vous êtes le premier joueur vous
commencez par prendre trois bâtons et
ensuite chaque fois que c'est à votre
tour de jouer
si votre adversaire a pris elle bat on
vous en prenez 4 - z c'est à dire s'il
en a pris 1 vous en prenez 3 s'il en a
pris 2 vous en prenez 2 et s'il en a
pris trois vous en prenez un et vous
pouvez vous convaincre que cette
stratégie eh ben elle vous permet de
gagner à tous les coups
donc puisqu'il existe une stratégie
imbattable pour gagner au jeu des
bâtonnets on dit que le jeu est résolu
alors évidemment vous voyez que ça ça
marche que si vous êtes le premier
joueur qui vous est le deuxième joueur
et que le premier joueur applique la
stratégie que j'aime vous le nez et ben
vous pourrez jamais gagné alors pour
certains jeux la situation avait un
petit peu différente dans les jeux où il
n'y a pas forcément un gagnant où il
peut y avoir match nul par exemple celta
du morpion alors le morpion il est aussi
résolu dans ce sens que on connaît des
stratégies qui permettent de ne jamais
perdre c'est à dire de faire à coup sûr
soit matches nuls soit gagner la partie
évidemment si les deux personnes
connaissent ces stratégies ça devient
vite assez chiant puisque ça veut dire
que la partie va être tout le temps car
il ya un certain nombre de jeux un petit
peu plus subtil que le morpion qui ont
déjà été résolus c'est le cas notamment
du jeu de dames et c'est aussi le cas
d'une puissance 4 il existe une
stratégie si vous êtes le premier joueur
je crois qui permet à coup sûr de gagner
au puissance 4 alors les échecs eux
n'ont pas encore été résolus c'est
d'ailleurs assez peu probable qu'ils le
soient c'est à dire qu' il existe
peut-être une stratégie imbattable mais
à ce jour elle n'a pas été découverte
alors pour certains jeux la stratégie
infaillible peut prendre une forme
aléatoire je vais prendre l'exemple du
jeu pierre feuille ciseaux il existe une
stratégie imbattable au pierre feuille
ciseaux
c'est de jouer soit pierre soit feuilles
choix ciseaux avec exactement est
parfaitement une probabilité d'un tiers
pour chaque donc vous jouez et à chaque
fois que c'est votre tour de jouer vous
tiré de manière absolument au hasard
parmi les 3 et si vous faites ça vous
êtes sûre sur le long terme de ne jamais
perdre alors évidemment à court terme
sur un coup vous pouvez très bien perdre
mais à long terme moment où le facteur
chance va disparaît vous êtes sûr avec
cette stratégie là de ne pas perdre
alors venons en maintenant au poker la
variante du poker dont on va parler
aujourd'hui c'est le head
limit hold'em donc le hold'em je pense
que vous connaissez c'est la variante
moderne du poker c'est celle où chaque
joueur ne possède que deux cartes qui
gardent cacher et où on a jusqu'à cinq
cartes en commun pour tous les joueurs
alors on va se placer dans la situation
qu'on appelle head's up c'est à dire où
on n'a que deux joueurs un contrat est
la variante plus précises qu'on
considère c'est la variante qu'on
appelle limite c'est à dire que c'est
une situation où le montant de la
relance est fixé c'est-à-dire que quand
c'est votre tour de jouer vous n'avez
que trois choses possible que vous
pouvez faire c'est suivre vous coucher
ou bien relancé d'une quantité fixe
allant fixe une quantité par exemple de
jetons et donc la relance et elle est
toujours de deux jetons alors comme pour
les échecs il ya des gens qui ont
commencé à essayer de faire des
programmes informatiques qui soit
capable de jouer au poker dans cette
variante là il ya notamment un groupe de
recherche à l'université de moncton au
canada qui a en 2007 a publié un
programme qui pour la première fois
était capable de battre des joueurs
professionnels de poker c'est un
programme qui s'appelait paul harris
alors ce programme il était très très
fort il battait des pros mais il n'était
pas mathématiquement imbattable il était
juste très fort comme les programmes qui
joue aux échecs
aujourd'hui et début 2015 cette même
équipe a poussé le bouchon beaucoup plus
loin puisque cette fois ils ont résolu
le jeu de poker dans cette variante est
the limit
c'est à dire qu'ils ont publié un
nouveau programme qui s'appelle ces
faits us et qui lui est mathématiquement
imbattable alors évidemment quand on dit
qu'un programme de poker est
mathématiquement imbattable c'est comme
pour le pire feuille ciseaux ça doit
s'entendre sur le long terme c'est à
dire que si vous jouez juste un seul
tour avec lui les vous avez une paire
d'as ya de bonnes chances que vous le
boîtier mais sur le long terme quand le
facteur chance annuler
eh ben vous pourrez jamais le battre
quelle que soit la stratégie que vous
allez jouer
alors je suis sûr que vous avez envie
d'en savoir un peu plus sur cette
fameuse stratégie mise au point par ces
faits luce alors heureusement pour
l'intérêt du poker elle tient pas du
tout en deux lignes comme dans le cas du
jeu des bâtonnets en fait elle est même
tellement complexe que rien que pour
stocker la stratégie il faut 11
téraoctets de disques durs alors ce qui
est intéressant c'est de savoir que pour
mettre au point cette stratégie en fait
les concepteurs du programme l'ont fait
jouer contre lui même un grand nombre de
fois et en fait pendant deux mois
ces foetus a joué contre lui même en
faisant environ 6 milliards de partie
par seconde
6 milliard de parties par seconde
pendant deux mois c'est à dire que
probablement à chaque seconde
ces faits us a joué plus de parties de
poker que toute l'humanité
depuis l'invention du poker alors même
si la stratégie suivie par ces faits
ussel et probablement pas applicable
pour des humains c'est quand même
intéressant de voir ce que ça peut nous
apprendre sur la manière de jouer au
poker alors déjà vous pouvez aller sur
le site de l'université des deux
montagnes et vous pouvez jouer contre
ces faits us pour voir comment il se
comporte
vous pouvez aussi lui soumettre des
situations c'est à dire que vous lui
dites quels sont vos car qu'est-ce qui
est sorti comment les gens ont renchéri
et c'est fait tu dois vous dire quelle
est la stratégie optimale à suivre dans
ce genre de situation une autre chose
qui est utile c'est de voir comment ces
fusent jouant tout début de tour
c'est-à-dire au moment où on a juste
deux cartes et où rien n'est sorti et on
peut voir que ces faits us a tendance à
suivre des stratégies qui sont
relativement agressive c'est à dire que
par exemple quand il est le donneur
notamment ces foetus ne suis jamais soit
is couche quand il a vraiment un jeu
pourri soit il relance et ce qui est
marrant c'est que il relance même avec
un jeu qu'on aurait envie de juger
vraiment court comme par exemple 1 4 et
1 6 qui sont même pas de la même couleur
alors pour les puristes évidemment la
version du poker dont on parle
aujourd'hui elle est quand même
relativement restreinte déjà c'est
seulement deux joueurs et puis donc je
vous ai dit c'est la version limite
c'est-à-dire une version où le montant
de la relance et fixes ce qui empêche
toutes les stratégies du genre je
relance comme un malade je fais tapis
etc
donc il ya quand même toute une partie
de la psychologie du poker qui est
absente de cette version là il n'empêche
que le groupe de l'université de moncton
continue de travailler sur ces questions
là et peut-être qu'un jour ils vont
sortir un programme qui sera déjà
incapable de battre des
humains professionnel au no limit et
puis peut-être un jour complètement
résoudre le poker no limit mais ça il va
falloir attendre pour le savoir
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo j'espère
qu'elle vous a plu et qu'elle voudra
donner envie de vous intéresser un peu à
toutes ces questions mathématiques de
stratégie dans les jeux n'hésitez pas à
partager la vidéo c'est comme d'habitude
le seul moyen que na de faire connaître
la chaîne vous pouvez me retrouver sur
facebook sur twitter vous pouvez aussi
me soutenir sur tipi merci à tous les
types heures qui me soutiennent et vous
pouvez me retrouver sur mon blog qui
s'appelle science étonnante
merci et à bientôt